all right and ready you gotta be the
rest three two One Dingo
oh
[ __ ]
let's go what a dog fight oh okay oh
nice oh my god oh this producer problems
[Music]
thank you
so you mentioned the girls that might be
your audience is more like what 40ish
what oh you're a woman yeah so just
remind and then uh browse said something
about uh weddings yeah The Wedding
Singer so the number is reminding me my
friend's wedding
I sang at the wedding and as I'm singing
older white women were just [ __ ]
running and trying to touch or something
I'm just trying to sing and then after I
was done they kept trying to drag me to
their tables to take drinks with them so
I just thought like we'd be a perfect
[ __ ] fit for your show I I think so
too yeah flashbacks to Shannon yeah last
day of his life I have pictures of it
too somewhere
um he's saying When a Man Loves a Woman
that's the Michael Bolton version yeah
yeah
it was it was a lot of power ballad it
is when you say it's the Michael Bolton
version is there a different because
it's Percy Sledge yeah so Percy Sledge
is the original singer of it but Michael
bull did his kind of take on it oh
they're different they are they're a
little bit different yeah so it'd be
like Dixie Chicks version of landslide
as opposed to Stevie Nicks yes exactly
it's kind of it's very similar but
there's just a little bit of you know
they just add a little bit of different
taste to it because you perform
Landslide at our show sometimes which
version do you do
landslide
you did Landslide last year no
not landslide
oh brows question for our music it is
yeah we'll get to the question we should
intro I wasn't sure if we were recording
or not I didn't know where that storm
was gonna go it was okay
it's all right older women love when
chin sings [ __ ] older white women
white women yeah speaking about her
white women
welcome to cats after dark rest of Peace
Queen Elizabeth we are breaking that
news also
she died when the memes are already
coming out in full force
I had no idea why are you guys why is
everyone doing this I don't know
that's what you do for the queen
I've heard she's been dead for months
and that they were waiting for
they were waiting for um because it's
like what her 70th like Jubilee or 70
years in range that's when uh Chappelle
was in London yeah and they were waiting
for
um like they didn't want her to die like
69 years
like you're raining because they're like
oh all the memes so they've been hiding
no freaking way
that sounds like an internet rumor
that's exactly where I found it yeah
definitely the the I believe
that she has been dead for a long time
like I don't think that's a crazy
conspiracy theory because they didn't
want 69 memes I think that might be
though yeah but George is saying it's
impossible
I'm just trying to suss out you know my
opinion what do I believe like when it
hits my ear I'm like that yeah my sister
texted her family group chat she's like
Queen Elizabeth Elizabeth died like and
I just respond bluntly she's been dead
for months
period you're like Jesus like did you
kill her uh this is very popular but I
think that was the same thing about uh
RBG Ruth Bader Ginsburg I think she was
[ __ ] weekend at Bernie for a while I
believe
uh we can our skin looked quite pale she
was a little cold to the touch have you
ever seen the clip win
um Donald Trump finds out that Ruth
Bader Ginsburg died oh my God find this
it's incredible because it he just came
off a plane uh I I kind of yeah and for
some reason this is an added in post
Tiny Dancer was planning when he was
walking off amazing and someone someone
tells him and he's like what
and he has to like respond to the moment
and it actually turned off okay but with
him walking with tiny dancer was it
totally close now
but I feel like because some people is
like yeah but he just did like the
finger like kind of like this I can but
like
um but yeah that's that's an all-time
short moment right there I want to see
if that's real is that that's actually
in them is that actually in there though
Tiny's answer yes it has you could hear
it like that was C-SPAN that posted that
that's that's why it feels more real you
could hear it within the speakers too
yeah that sounds like a distant speaker
yeah like they would have had to like
doctor it up to like add it in there to
sound like that but it was loud too so
it's kind of like I don't know but it's
on C-Span yeah it was weird at least it
was a YMCA like that's Trump's favorite
song to play he's like he gets the crowd
pumped he gives the crowd bummed I love
the YMCA everyone dances it I can I felt
like you kind of like you were committed
right in their first couple syllables
but then you like every accent
you're like in your head you're like I
got this it happens to be too and then
you just start hearing it and you just
you're looking at people's faces and
lose confidence but I think I heard it
right away like a little bit it's just
the pursed lips and the the arrogance of
it again it's there that's halfway there
yeah
he's thinking back up let me think uh
welcome back browse thanks guys glad to
be back it's been a minute we got a
fight a minute it's been freaking week
we gotta fight I'm glad you brought that
up too
we are
[ __ ] I was waiting till you got As
skinny as possible and withered away but
you've been fluctuating now you're back
up yeah you took so long that I'm now
okay
it's 182 182. 12 pounds but like I I was
I was 176 at the end of that day yeah he
actually did a watered freaking fast or
whatever the hell
and it bumps me out thinking about
because I I like there's no reason to
ever do it again and I feel like I could
have gotten way way lower but I like ran
out of time
um but so if anybody ever wants to bet
me again I would love an excuse to push
myself but I need some compensation
you like the discipline aspect of it
don't you I do I just like I like yeah
doing [ __ ] like that but then also
there's just nothing on the line if
you're like oh I'm gonna lose 15 pounds
or ammo you're gonna eat this much or
whatever it's just not as fun for me I
don't know I need like sometimes it's
your life on the line
uh but it was fun I want the next thing
I want to do I really want to try to
dunk two-handed and like I've been
following this guy from my hometown for
a while who's like he's just on the
street you've been following
and he can do it
sometimes he goes to the park and I see
him his branding is like jump science
that says like Instagram account and
he's just he was like a study physical
therapy and he just trains athletes and
he lots of like D1 athletes
um
I think he trained um
[ __ ] the guy from Wisconsin the point
guard who is Johnny Davis uh he's from
my hometown I think he I think he
trained him and I just want to follow
his jump Science Program see if it can
dunk two-handed in like two months I
think you got that I used to be able to
dunk one-handed back in the day off one
foot but two two foot so much cooler
yeah two-handed two footed that's right
you ever been thrown down
I don't think I think a volleyball you
could or I can dunk a volleyball let's
not have a basketball I know that's what
I'm saying yeah that's like a big part
of it you gotta be able to like Palm the
ball you know
have you heard not yeah yeah one-handed
off one foot gotcha and like if I if I
have a ball I can just barely Palm it to
the point where like I could I could
swing it around like this but if I like
if you like tap it and fall on my hand
but you can get it up there
fascinating but no that is I I if I add
track it and I do it now I'm putting it
down on wax I want to dunk by
December 1st okay you said two footed
dunk though right two-handed two foot or
two-handed challenge made okay
I can
are you about to pull up a video how is
that I I've never dunked in my life do
you follow knees over toes guys I talk
to them like oh my bad let's put
headphones out
the producer should have headphones on
because then you know if you're too
quiet but I did uh my music question was
whatever happened to uh Taio Cruz
oh great question yeah I've been
listening to a lot of uh dynamite and
break your heart and great songs and
it's just like it feels like he
disappeared and like no idea I remember
his moment on the radio but I couldn't
tell you the songs he had was Tiger
Cruise he says I'm only gonna break
break yeah break break oh snap I'm only
gonna break break you never heard that
John no when you said Tyler Cruz I
thought the guy that does like the
motivational speaker about money that's
[Music]
um
well what happened to him too I thought
you were talking about J Cruz
I don't know how that is
it sounds like I'm gonna have to find
another podcast to go on and ask that
question because you guys don't yeah
yeah we have a listener out there I've
been meaning to Wikipedia him but I just
haven't and I know that's not that like
high stakes of a thing to do or you
should just do it I could find that
information tile Cruz but I want there I
want to find an expert on it I think
secretly you're afraid what you're gonna
find
I want to know why Los Angeles likes
that song that's like
it's always on the radio all the time do
you know what I'm talking about oh um
black summer yeah I've never heard that
song before I came to LA and it's on the
radio every day Red Hot Chili Peppers in
in L.A yeah
like Jack FM that's always going to be
like that's all they play basically yeah
Jack fmn K Rock yeah yeah uh Lots uh we
I've had this discussion with people
before but it's like Sublime also it's
just like
you couldn't listen to the radio an hour
on those stations without hearing five
different okay Staples yeah The
Offspring yeah
um
people did you guys listen to Sublime
growing up it was huge in the midwest
like yeah five years
I guess it was kind of during the time
but it it it lived on for like hippie
Midwest kids yeah for until now like you
go back to a high school party and
probably hear [ __ ] Santeria not that
long before my brother passed away we
took a road trip and we just listened to
his whole entire like the whole best of
sublime CD and it was him my dad and me
like three chubby giant humans
that poor car
yeah I know it was a fun time I didn't
know they formed in 1988 I didn't know
that goddamn I didn't know that either
they've been around for a minute yeah
but the the lead singer died really fast
especially when they're blowing up it
sucks you're so talented before their
album blew up I have his name at the tip
of my tongue but I can just think of
Bradley Martin no it's Russell Bradley
Knoll that's close enough that'd be
weird Bradley Martin faked his death as
a Sublime lead singer and then started
to do culture yeah honestly like give
you all the [ __ ] testosterone and
steroids you have I needed them to not
know who I was let's make an iceberg
that's not like that's not too crazy but
he's so tall Brady knows everyone knows
he's on yeah yeah could you actually go
to Google reviews of zoo culture
do you guys know about this
you don't you don't know about this I
think I do is it the cell drugs thing
yeah okay don't step on it but yeah
this is a great promo you're welcome bro
I feel like they it is a great great
selling point it's basically like if you
want to get [ __ ] jacked and this is
probably a lot uh Steve will do it maybe
had a big influence on this is is that
what happened today yeah do they have
some I'm so
this is a perfect segue in into uh the
Youtube rabbit holes that I wanted to
discuss because the milk boys is like a
whole nother thing that's like obviously
I know they're big and giant but it's
like a blind spot I didn't really know
what they do but he had the milk boys
also beefing with Bradley Martin
I don't know if that's happening now but
I think Steve will do it always trolls
him and says like Bradley Martin sells
me drugs no so like and anything Steve
will do it says like comments just go
crazy with people you know what I'm
saying there was a guy when I was when I
would work out at zoo culture there was
a guy
scrawny scrawny little guy
would walk into Zoo culture with a white
T-shirt on that says Bradley Martin
sells me drugs right and I saw the guy
at least three different times in hot
like randomly throughout LA and every
time I saw him he had that same exact
shirt on it's insane he just walks in
and like I don't even think he knows
Brad he just because Steve will do it
said it everyone just ran with it and
like he doesn't care that people are in
his gym with that on or [ __ ] I think he
thinks like I is he there all the time
not all the time like when I first
started going there he was there a lot
and then he kind of like didn't there
were like were weeks like where he
wasn't there because he'd be in Miami or
just like pawn star guys they're not
really always at the shop I will say
Chumley's not really behind the glass
a lot more likely to come down your
chips
you will [ __ ] hold you off put a gun
to your head and probably have a bunch
of math but
on Stars what a show I firmly believe
part of its success was young men like
me scrolling past and be like what's
that say yeah
and there was like the TNT like spin-off
that was uh like the pawn shop in
Detroit and it was called Hardcore Pawn
there you go Nick this is what you're
looking for
yeah some of them are like long and
funny but if you can't find them I can't
read anymore
substance behind the gym that person
definitely like was had to be injected
in the steroids wrong because he
misspelled everything in that sentence I
think it's meme or talk you know no I
think even Steve will do it had a full
like rally at
people like showed up like hundreds of
people like Bradley Martin sells me
drugs no signs and [ __ ] they closed the
gym because of that yeah for the day
because there was a huge like because
they had awareness
I'm so glad I don't go there anymore
the only performance enhancers you're
gonna get at Cafe very dark is Magic
Mike yeah thank you sir what's Magic Man
uh you haven't heard so glad you asked
do we only have two bottles left there's
a bunch of warm ones I have a warm one
so I can have a cold one BRB
you
would have caught it had you already had
it
um yeah magic mind it it's the
anti-procrastination drink I think that
uh something we all deal with it's
procrastination you know we're ambitious
young fellas but sometimes you're tasks
your to-do list just seem so daunting
yeah you take this it's a nice calm Zen
Focus filled with 12 natural ingredients
echinacea ashwagandha 10 others and uh
you'll take it and it gives you a nice
Zen Focus hum throughout the day to help
you start knocking off your to-do list
rather than seeing it grow uh George is
bringing in some more and we're all
gonna have it honestly go to
magicmind.com
for 20 off 20 or yeah for 20 that's
awesome uh promo code dark and if you
don't this show will end in Eight
Episodes because I'm not going to do it
for free
that Eight Episodes okay think of this
like Joe Budden Spotify contract right
that's another rabbit hole
the last three days all I've done is
watch YouTube wait what's up with uh Joe
Biden's Spotify uh we'll drink this
magicmine.com
promo code dark 20 off
start [ __ ] accomplishing more cheers
more stress less drink your magic man I
did I polish It Off
it's not the only thing you polish off
huh no my shoes because I have a wedding
to go to honestly I love this stuff like
no lie it tastes like I love green tea
it's such a good flavor I am now like
fully like I enjoy it sometimes if I'm
on an empty stomach it will give give me
like a little bit of gut rot but uh oh
that's not good for that I know
cut it out hey if you have that much
nutrients in something it's gonna feel
weird entering your body I take so many
vitamins a day that like any time
between like six in the morning and like
whenever I eat lunch if I burp it's just
like oh there's an alphabet of vitamins
yeah and if I have a coffee on an empty
stomach it's a thousand times worse
worse I can feel like just have like a
piece of toast or something I I know I
[ __ ] banana I go back and forth
between I don't like eating breakfast I
don't know Uncrustables if I eat a
little bit in the morning then I then
all of a sudden I'm hungry but if I
don't then I can like go
out same here yeah no same but gut
roster sounds terrible when I wake up
what's up you guys drink coffee right
when you wake up I do yeah yeah I just
uh oh plug for another podcast show we
just all ate the Hot Chip what are you
doing Christian influencers in the wild
that is unbelievable
dude when I edit I can see all five
cameras and there'll just be times
Christians like
it's like when we have a zoom or
something so it is to pull something up
but he's just completely checked out no
I'm listening
to your phone
but uh be real tell me yeah what the
[ __ ] is be real what I was just being
real and I got called out for it you get
a notification it's the and then you
like you get like a notification like
it's two minutes to be real so you take
a picture rear facing camera so I got
all you guys and then front facing
camera and then you be real that's what
you posted on Instagram post on be real
it's owned by China and they get all of
our information dude wow so am I come on
why are you saying that information
recognition because he's Korean
[Laughter]
but yeah it's like the first it's the
first social media app in a while
basically since Clubhouse that's had
like a little bit of [ __ ] momentum in
the Zeitgeist and yeah you basically
you're just gonna how long do you have
you get a notification and you have to
you can post you get the notification
and you can do it whenever like so let's
say I didn't do it say waited like an
hour it would let everyone know that
like oh Christian posted an hour late or
like you can post it right on time and
then it doesn't really matter when you
post it but when you take a picture you
have two minutes to take the picture and
then it shows you how many retakes you
took like if someone went to my thing
and clicked on a picture it showed them
where it was taken how many retakes
people react to it comment on it where
it was taken how do so and it
how does it like
how can you start finding other people
or like how does it feed you other
content
um so you there is a friends Tab in a
discovery tab look where it keeps me
young
I feel like I keep young and I age you
sometimes yeah
[Laughter]
it is a fun app there's a discovery type
like where you like when people post it
like you can see what someone's doing at
the moment in like Berlin or like all
over the world it's just a discovery
type of just endless people give a [ __ ]
how many followers are you I don't care
I have like 60 friends like like all
just close friends wow
it's just like I think it's interesting
because like there are people fun social
uh like
some of these they start with your
friends like Snapchat friends yeah so
like that could be that could be fun I
could see that well it was wild during
like like when the war with Ukraine
first started popping off there were
people like there was like a mortar
going off in the background people are
doing it to be real I'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on is that the thing you
do no it's just something I do like made
me feel like less awkward you know than
just staring at the camera yeah that
should have made you feel way more
honest I feel like Will Ferrell
ends like so like I'm just like always
like that or does it randomly tell you
when to take the pictures it like
randomly throughout the day like someday
some days it will be two o'clock two
days in a row then it'll be like seven
o'clock like the next day
if I'm around you yeah yeah I saw what
like people repost them on Twitter and
[ __ ] and it was like craziest b-real of
all time and it's like
is someone opened their oven in this
giant Fireball came out
but it's like you that guy
that kind of how long after you guys
posted because he was like he's waiting
for that [ __ ] yeah that's why it tells
you it tells you how long basically
that's why people can tell like maybe
you're setting it up for what I'd be
sick if uh Prince Charles got one right
now it's like oh King now [ __ ] the
funniest thing is I got one at my
grandfather's funeral and I did post one
like in front of like like as a joke I
did it in front of my grandfather's
casket you say as a joke but you did it
I know but like realistically I did it
for three people to laugh my two
brothers and my cousins I mean I bet
your Grandpa would have gotten a kick
out of it oh yeah well yeah he would
have if some of the other family members
probably Jesus [ __ ] but they're not
real enough okay yeah I'm not saying
just be real like you know yeah it's I
just like knowing when these likes pop
up and then
watching them burn okay that is really
fun too like the amount of like the
whole time I thought Clubhouse is
[ __ ] stupid like yeah yeah uh but
they have actually like
their Tech has like worked because like
Twitter spaces are like a real thing and
uh but yeah I don't know anybody who's
on clubhouse I haven't heard of
Clubhouse I'm so old school you want to
know what's wild too Instagram so you
know how Instagram basically stole Tick
Tock yeah yeah they're stole they stole
be real now too they're releasing a
thing called Candid captures where
alerts you out throughout the day and it
has the rear-facing camera and the
forward-facing camera and their talent
like yeah we're gonna roll it out it's
just some wild thing we decided to do
you know completely random we want to
try it out I like squashing the little
guy yeah yeah they literally take
everything I love Steve that's called
capism all right you have the
opportunity in this country to start any
company you want it will get stolen what
is more real than capitalism yeah uh I
remember they did it to Snapchat too
when they had it when they added stories
and
it was when I was producing at the
podcast one and I did Joe Coy's podcast
so like he always had these like
Filipino influencers and stuff and
guests Filipino people when there is a
new social media are the first one on it
I had like on your stories how it shows
like all the people who have posted them
the first day it was live it was just 12
Filipino people and then like no no you
couldn't watch any other stories because
people didn't know what it was they love
social media like I get it you're a
nurse get out of here
but when you're an early adopter and if
you're right and it like pops off then
it's like it can be huge for you like
yeah like browse on the truth social
were you big on true social truth social
that's trumps
what else was on the first one on there
do you guys just see how wide Nick's
eyes went like he was so happy about it
are you on are you actually on Rubble no
no oh God damn it what was that I don't
even know is that where Andrew another
podcast network is exclusive yeah
yeah APN Soul should we sign up
um what was the there was another one
before Rumble that was like a
conservative one part A Part par parlor
yeah oh yeah I I I'd have to update it
but I have parlor on my phone I got real
Nick Davis
I couldn't risk somebody taking my name
and exposing me
uh but Joe Joe Budden that was one of
the rabbit holes I went to oh yeah let
me tell you to take you on this journey
and I would love to hear the last thing
you got sucked down yours seems very
different you said ice wall yeah
Antarctic cheeks are are fresh waters
poisoned is that what it was about no it
was uh that like so it goes with like
the Flat Earth
um thing and the ice wall that keeps all
the water yeah and then after the ice
wall is like more undiscovered lands and
stuff and they're like all like
harboring that like they the elites are
all like harboring that and those
resources for themselves yeah and it
kind of goes into the hollow Earth uh
Theory but yeah I just like I'm seeing a
lot of that stuff on Tick Tock right now
at the Antarctic Ice wall and just like
some random dude like reading like a few
like things that he's just regurgitating
like oh wow
do you actually believe that though no
it's fun to like oh yeah
I as as long as you didn't believe that
then okay
I wish I would watch I would like for
that to be real I watched God for
something yeah I watched Skull Island
King Kong yeah so uh Hollow Earth is
completely plausible no is it have you
seen King Kong's calling give me give me
Hollow Earth what's Hollow Earth that's
uh that is basically that the Earth is
hollow inside and like all the creatures
and [ __ ] all the crap people
basically anything that like Bigfoot
anything that you can't explain it's
like oh they're in the middle of there
it's like for real Ah that's what Lord
of the Rings was about oh [ __ ] see he
was onto something uh Kyrie believes and
this is like a common flight that it's
uh that's shaped like an eye so like
it's flat but then underneath yeah yeah
ten tendrical yeah he thinks the Earth
is shaped like that yeah yeah uh Kyrie
Irving just yellow yeah I've seen those
pictures on Google of like the yeah
illustration
I like that donut
uh did you that one the side shape
second to right on the
um is kind of like second to right on
the top this one oh second to write this
yeah yeah that one yeah I like that okay
that's cool that's I think that's the mo
if you if you'd like drill down on flat
earthers like what's the shape then like
they don't just think it's like this
disc that's like flat I think that's
Minecraft yeah I was gonna say that I
want to have a house on the bottom side
[ __ ] Mordor but you you know what I
don't understand is people think that
it's a flat Earth but look at all the
pictures and videos that we've seen live
streams and everything
you think
I'm just saying that's what they say
yeah I I I'm we're just saying you're a
[ __ ] sheep and listen you think all
the astronauts all the ones you get from
school this guy all the people that have
been involved you don't think won since
since the first moon landing you don't
think there's gonna be one of those
people that be like yeah listen man the
Earth is actually flat look up the first
look up the first interview from when
they came back from the Moon look how
weird he's acting I've seen Joe Rogan
before come on Christian call it up
Christian prove it to us just go try to
run around the earth I promise you don't
make it back yeah
start now [ __ ] you got me there
first interview back I'm getting another
course and I'm telling you about this
YouTube rabbit hole it was a jerk
you think
no I'm a vape [ __ ]
this one
where were you bro you died he was in
the Middle Earth hollow Earth yeah I'm
interested now I need to see this George
show you need to help Joe Rogan
oh cause that's that's what makes it
okay where do you think I get my
knowledge from I didn't go to college
to Jr University but how did your uh
kiddos tournament go did that happen was
that a thing tournament did I make it up
that was a while ago but oh yeah
did she win here in a while yeah hey I
said well you haven't been here in a
while so yeah I've been there I've been
in Ohio but it just happened I can't say
I'd want to hear about this
hey you said bam you said damn okay I
wonder how mean that comes across but uh
it was maybe a seven you're like yeah I
went five no it was it was more funny
than me so I I think that was okay if
you have kids you understand people like
that's nice talk
how old is you do you have kids
I'm Uncle George I got nieces and
nephews I can talk about dumb [ __ ] they
do all day that nobody cares about your
daughter's what eight eleven oh
how old are you right now 31. damn
you're old
game was weak
I don't think I've ever was she
planned or not no okay okay I told you
she's 19. I was getting deep I know so
many kids I'm like bro I know kids my
age who were having kids when they were
graduating and getting married and [ __ ]
one of the kids I went to high school
with who still sells drugs named his kid
nacho like I'm not even kidding yeah
sorry buddy that's not your kid
they better not go on board
I'm not kidding his his son's name is
Nacho Libre Adams is the kid's name
no no no that's gonna be the best kid in
the world but honestly will probably be
turned out do you guys funny it's like
he's got fire sharpens you do you guys
know my mom legitimately tried to name
me Scooby-Doo Harris
my mom you do look like a Scooby I know
right with my mom yeah just you
but no my mom legitimately she never got
the name any of her kids and I was her
last kid good reason what do you want to
name him something like something fun
like Scooby-Doo and they were like no
that's why we don't let you do that part
they're like how about your father's
name George Harris the second I'm like
yeah and that's me no that's my history
that's why we have I I miss you got to
pick I missed it no no no no
he's like eight years old he spun the
wheel yeah I pulled my head I said don't
anything but yeah please
okay I hear it now I hear it now it
starts with
you guys no jumper yep uh Adam 22 M22 uh
man I like
it took me a while but he is one of the
best interviewers yeah like he's so well
versed on his on his guests and he just
lets him talk he doesn't like interrupt
it's amazing but he had Andrew Callahan
on yeah and I also thought he just like
kind of [ __ ] latched on to like rap
and just got famous from that but adam22
has been hustling for like did you watch
the Warren Shire or the Chiraq video
that channel 5 put out Andrew Callahan
the old black one I did that's I love it
it was crazy because like a week ago on
another podcast show
my buddy Pat is like he's almost 50. he
like just had heard of young gravy young
gravy's having like a moment because
he's yeah his PR team is just Peyton
Madison Ray's mom now yeah and then he
so like Pat's like playing this music
he's like I can't believe this is what
the kids are listening to I'm like this
isn't what the kids are listening to
this is like universally considered
cringe uh what they listen to is black
people killing themselves in Chicago
like driller [ __ ] that's what's Brooklyn
in hip-hop is that not like it's
Brooklyn girl drill Music Brooklyn drill
Chicago Trail yeah Chicago started Drew
yeah Chicago started drill I thought
Brooklyn did no no Chicago she literally
yeah
all of them growing up in Oh Black
together wait people still listen to
Chief Keef Chief Keef was lit like that
was my prime time like eighth like high
school that were like even before that
that's when Chief Chief Keef was 16 and
I was like 11. and I'm just like I hate
[ __ ]
that music video came out which is
insane to think about yeah it was a long
time but pop smoke really started to
make all right you hang out with the
guys from Power
he was better I mean the only uh Chicago
artist I like is really King vong RP and
Polo G that's it I haven't heard any of
the music yeah this is like I'm just
from there so I'm a lot more deeply
connected this is my youth I like having
my like knowing like what's going on but
it's like I listen to like one song I
don't know they sound similar to me I
sound like old as [ __ ] I'm sorry I like
J Cole that makes me an old hip hop
I claim Brooklyn drill because the only
rappers we got where I'm from is Mike
Stud how many rapper we got hey so
adam22 has Andrew Callahan from Channel
5 on and they just start talking about
all the [ __ ] like basically Andrew
Callahan's uh thing was like he wanted
or he was trying to confront Adam 22
about having all these rappers who were
involved with the driller [ __ ] and
killing and like he's like do you feel
any responsibility for like pushing this
out to the masses and that was a lot of
the Crux of the conversation because
Andrew was like there's all these
YouTube documentaries that are like
glorifying it so obviously I had to find
find those documentaries and then I
found this guy trap lore Ross who does
like two and a half
our documentaries I'm gonna air you drop
you this one clip I screen recorded on
what's going on in like Jacksonville
Toronto Chicago the war of Chiraq and
it's like yeah it's super depressing but
it's also like fascinating
um and the guy trap or Ross is so good
at it he's such a good narrator uh do
you have your
my airdrop should be on
I'm glad I didn't know this is the
rabbit hole you were talking about this
is I thought you were going to talk
about some crazy Rabbit Hole YouTube
[ __ ] uh this is cool and then also on
Andrew and Adam 22 started talking about
[ __ ] Mac Oh [ __ ] Mac I love [ __ ] Mack is
hilarious I I only see I'm a fan of
Andrew Callahan so that's how I found
all oh yeah yeah shrimp who's that
sounds like cryptocurrency like yeah
yeah
I have 1 000 shares occurred back yeah I
would invest yeah but he is just Tyler
Winklevoss is the [ __ ] Matt Tyler
that's that's a Bitcoin joke oh okay
uh yeah yeah
so this is trapler Ross and this is from
like the Jacksonville murder doctor
these are legits right here that's the
Florida term for kids by flip the
youngin and Trigger Roma
say you and me that's me I think
priled he actually started rapping at
the young age of 14 finding himself
rolling with a crew of rapping G's
called younging Gat a crew apparently
founded by Philip the youngin and
Trigger Roma they were holding me I was
young but they namely suspended like
y-u-n-g so Ace along with this young
gang boys made songs like the early
track go to war which came along with a
music video where they were showing off
some heavy artillery hell at one point a
dude even pulls out a World War one
looking rifle with a goddamn banging
that at the end because these guys are
in the trenches for real for real now
imagine his videos
that were around ace in the early days
of his career that includes
this guy is amazing
it's funny yeah
uh and he like and he's like a long time
hip-hop fan so he really listens to all
this [ __ ] and everything okay back there
I know what the [ __ ] going on dude
you guys are just high as [ __ ]
well do you look just super hot
a gun with a baby
from World War two one
so you could watch that for forever that
was about a half a day I I learned about
all these this this rap [ __ ] but then I
backed out oh I ended up back at
Traveler Ross and then he had a whole
thing about the collapse of the Joe
Budden podcast uh-huh do you know
anything about his his podcast he he was
I know they split up and there was beef
but I didn't look into it any more than
that Joe Biden sounds like his entire
career he's like
had success and then he [ __ ] it up
constantly because he's like an
egomaniac I remember he was in like all
the m m ciphers back in the day yeah and
then he got first he got into our this
was all trap lauras taught me at all
okay he was first in an argument with
Jay-Z got fired from Def Jam and then he
was with Eminem they got into beef then
he started his podcast that blew up in
2019 it was the biggest uh podcast on
Spotify he got he got over 10 million
dollars from Spotify for The Joe Rogan
deal
um and then but then like his two guys
who were on the podcast uh Mal and Rory
they start they basically like wanted
Equity it's like a tale as old as time
like things get bigger they're like oh
we've been part of it he's like I
started it and
that so that all collapsed but then uh
Adam 22 is on Joe Budden and they had a
whole whole thing and Joe Budden was
basically trying to say like Adam 22 is
like also perpetuating all these these
gang guys getting killed and oh and like
a culture vulture kind of culture
vulture and taking advantage because he
will repost when someone he's had 12
people on a show that have died yeah
like like that was their last year no uh
are you serious well he finds this like
maybe even more yeah like all the early
rappers like Lil Peep and everything
like he finds people early and kind of
puts them on but I mean a lot of them
just develop drug problems and like over
so death from overdosing not actually
murdered so there's something gang
violent deaths as well wow and then
he'll repost right after which
I am on the side
as he was trying to defend himself that
is
but also like
obviously it's a little opportunistic
and there is benefit for him reposting
it but like that's what people want to
see and like hear they want to hear
these people in interviews like before
they died and stuff so like I don't
really think it's like unless it's
something that makes them look bad but
it's like something they wanted to put
out there I think that is what do you
guys have thoughts on that do you think
it's like
uh exploit exploitative I don't like the
fact that it's like reposting so quick
after someone's death like that but he
puts a lot of people on too like those
kids want to go on his show a lot of
them blow up from it yeah yeah that
that's another thing that they were
trying to say like you're taking
advantage of these kids it's like a
young only fans girl but it's like
they're getting huge benefit like it's
they feel like they're going on Carson
if they get to call to be an M22 show
Adam he used to do a live stream that
people pay 200 just for him to like
listen to their song for like a minute
yeah like and just for that little bit
of promo during the live stream it's
like a set price of 200 just for you to
critique me and like criticize me on a
platform I love strange incredible
incredible business model oh yeah he's
smart with the money but I mean
I mean to get into the morals of it is
dicey because it's like maybe what you
put a claim at the beginning that's like
hey be responsible blah blah like is
that his responsibility to tell these
people this gang life isn't nice [ __ ]
that was another thing about like the
glorification of it and stuff but it's
like
you can't tell someone how to receive it
like when I see that [ __ ] I'm like this
is sad yeah I want this [ __ ] to end like
why are they killing each other over
nothing I'm not like oh I want to
[ __ ] kill someone now but here's the
thing like there's gonna be a whole
bunch of people clipping it anyways and
it's like that's your stuff like like do
you get ahead of it or like I don't know
Mark Mark Maron for years when someone
dies he posts he's done it with Patrice
O'Neill he's done it with Norm Macdonald
and I [ __ ] love that like
that was like wow you remember them and
like I don't know so it's yeah I mean I
guess it doesn't even because like think
about Queen Elizabeth just died it gets
posted everywhere instantly right see
and that was a lot of Adam's Adam's
thing he was he's talking about how I'm
a media company and this is like what
you do and when your audience wants it
like you put it out there but they're
like what about the families but they
kept putting all these hypotheticals
direct what if his mother asked you to
put it down but she didn't in fact you
don't even know how she feels about
maybe she is happy that's out there
again
um I do agree with browser there should
be like a little like after someone dies
like if he reposts it look I think there
should be like a little bit of a grace
period from when he posted like of it
say like you said Little People's on
before he died say like adam22 reposted
it the day Pete died I think that's like
a little much I think maybe he should
look wait like should be like a weak
grace period or something I feel like or
like a little bit of time though
that's I mean
Joe Budden would agree with you uh but I
I feel I feel like I don't I feel like
that's the time to post it like
yeah I don't know with the music stuff
like when people die and they like start
promoting their musical heavy I don't
like that you know what I'm saying like
there's like when you met your pop smoke
they talked like for weeks at a time
there was he was just straight rotation
like yeah
because that was okay because the height
of his career too like he was like
really like at the height right before
he died so and like Mac Miller when they
died they didn't really Pro they didn't
promote his [ __ ] that much they what he
dropped an album like a week or a year
later no no he dropped uh before he died
yeah it was swimming I think it was yeah
right before he died and there wasn't
even that much promotion around that I
don't think yeah it's tough but then
from that they were talking about one
specific guy who died who he reposted
and they had a really big problem with
and it was this guy who's semi like
Andrew Tate adjacent Kevin Samuels okay
uh and I had never heard of this guy and
he was [ __ ] huge he was about to have
a moment but like a year ago I think in
July of last year he died from a heart
attack
but man this guy was it's all in
separate rep this is like literally the
past four days yeah from ab22 to Andrew
Callahan to trap Laura Ross back to back
to Andrew Callahan Joe Budden
um but that I think I sent you a CL I
texted you a uh a link to
Uh Kevin Samuels is this not him I I
texted you a link there might be
um sorry but his he's basically he
started in PR
and he's kind of like a mover and a
Shaker but then he started to find like
YouTube success
telling he used to give advice to men
like how to like become a man uh build a
family blah blah blah but then he
started getting more traction when he
started telling women what they need to
do to like be better for men and he
became really controversial
uh he would talk to her he would have
these lines live streams of basically
coach women on like what they would ask
him advice but he'd be really harsh
about like
you're kind of average I don't know if
you should be looking for a man who has
six figures Ed
I don't know is when I realized how old
I am I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on I don't know what's going on here so
I'm just like what the [ __ ] he's like
Eddie Brown that's why I feel like I'm
having a midlife crisis because I just
went down like hip hop YouTube and man
there's some good [ __ ] out there
I really it's like a study in like what
creators are doing because I want them
more stuff that's like not just podcast
related but uh I don't know I have this
down and all this stuff is like
really intimidating I feel like it would
take months and I never put it out like
my Corey Feldman documentary you better
hurry up dude or wait till something
happens to him and then yeah bam
nice call back you can't do that you
can't say that either uh to go to uh
uh 1108
so this is his most viewed video and it
was on one of his live streams and he
has women oh this one actually started
out really funny because
he has his disagreement night where
women are supposed to call in and just
like combat his viewpoints but this
woman called in and she's like I wanna I
wanna ask your advice about something
he's like
uh but this is disagreement night
you know I'm trying to run a business
here if you want to ask me advice you
can book a session or you could try to
get out on the proper stream and she's
like well I'm a business owner you
should oh you're a business owner what
do you do with that business and she's
like I sell pet good she's like well if
you sold Pet Goods and someone comes in
tries to buy whatever the [ __ ] like how
would you feel he's like but this is a
teaching moment so I'm gonna ask me your
advice and then he just tears into this
woman and this is like when he started
yeah 1108 yep yeah is this where he
tears into the woman I mean it's
basically the whole 22 minutes but uh
she's also very unrealistic
but I have been working on myself this
year and um
okay man but okay 35 13 year old son
with a sketchy father why would a man
who's in the top 10 percent of earners
who women across the country he is she
has uh stated that she cannot find a man
who makes six figures or more because
she feels like she's very ambitious and
she has her own business where she makes
six figures so she's looking for a man
that has six figures but she's also told
him she's 35 she has a 13 year old son
her dad's not really in the picture and
oh
he want want that
um because I have a lot to offer
um I feel like would you want your son
to have you had a son making that kind
of money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son from a sketchy
father or would you prefer him to get a
woman who had no children who's younger
and easier to get on his program
foreign
[Music]
this is when he starts to get uh people
get pissed at him because he's he like
just causing a problem with black women
and he responded to this video of Tomi
lahren told me Larry put out some
Instagram live she's like PSA to men
this is why you're not finding what you
want like be reliable don't ghosts quick
quit hitting us up at 2 A.M and uh and
he he came in he's like they're ghosting
you because you're you're average Tommy
you're you're what I call it adaptable
six you can dial you up and you can be
an eight but you're six
he's just he's like uh Tom lycus yes
yeah yeah yeah I was comparing uh just
two weeks ago like Andrew Tate I felt
like he's a Tom like yeah yeah his
misogyny is a character but yeah they
also obviously believe it and I don't
know it's problematic but man yeah you
can you go back and listen to like old
Tom like his stuff and it's pretty it's
funny to like go back I never heard any
of it but I Adam carollo talked about
him a lot and both the guys on another
podcast show they both one of them his
dad listened to do it all the time with
him in the car and uh uh try to give
like
do like the 20 seconds of something Tom
likes would say he was an old
misogynistic yeah but he was like huge
like like radio guy in like the early
2000s and stuff like nationally
syndicated shock jock and he would just
be like yeah
um like [ __ ] the problem with these
[ __ ] yeah they they're just after
yours he'd be like treat women like crap
they like being treated like crap never
get married like getting married is like
the stupidest thing like a guy can do
why would you do that to yourself
um like they all end in divorce
um never um never take a girl out to
dinner
um don't spend more than like 20 on a
date like the goal is just to get laid
as quick as possible and for as cheap as
possible and like that kind of stuff and
a big thing he would do is like flash
Fridays so like everyone would be on the
like going into the weekend like driving
home from the weekend and be like all
right now it's time for Flash Fridays
and if you're listening in your car if
you're a guy you're supposed to like do
your high beams if you're a girl you're
supposed to flash like whoever like I
didn't know yeah that was like a big
thing did it happen yeah yeah yeah and
that was like a big like he would do
that all the time and the funny thing is
he's just like this like big fat like
gross like white dude he's like talking
about all this stuff and ladies will
call in and be like oh look at you and
he's like oh you're smart huh you're
smart huh you don't think I know that
about myself that's why I worked so hard
and get money and like yeah can you look
up top I've never actually seen a
picture of them Tom Leykis
l-e-y-k-i-s oh I remember him
still doing a podcast yeah he does
something behind a paywall yeah he's got
to be behind the paywall that
[ __ ] have Rumble he's behind
some wall
yeah
he's so good at like
any kind of debate he just changes the
how he is the the direction and then
[ __ ] always wins every single time
and he'll like talk about like a guy
who's like in a relationship with like a
bigger woman and he like knocked her up
and stuff and he's like he is a captive
he is a prisoner he has no life between
his eyes like behind his eyes that's so
he was actually really funny and really
smart too
um he he uh yeah unfortunately radio
died yeah he didn't adapt fast enough
but
I'm sure he probably does well on his
because like yo Killed the Radio Star
uh yeah just like old ass loneliness
we're definitely alone yeah
he was like his their hero he has like
all his old stuff on um
YouTube and it's like the same thing as
that guy like the old stuff's on there
yeah and you can listen to like a whole
bunch of like full episodes and it's the
same thing like
um God will be like oh yeah I've been
like seeing this girl like she has a kid
and stuff and I'm like kind of paying
for the kid and he's like why would you
ever pay for the kid that's not yours
like what are you doing and it's like
it's funny to hear someone else say it
like you don't necessarily have to agree
with everything intrusive thoughts and
they're all winning
I'm gonna have to look up those that
might be in a future another podcast to
show a segment like Great Moments again
yeah it would kind of be a follow-up to
Great Moments entire Banks history she
has some great great [ __ ] viral
moments which she used to have a talk
show Tyra Banks hates fat people and it
would all be like oh I wore a fat suit
for a day to see how it feels or like uh
I don't know
is she bigger yeah there is this uh
Chef who was on below deck a female chef
before she was a chef she was on
America's Next Top Model and
the that that has another like millions
and millions of like or thousands of
viral moments because they're they were
so mean to these women and she was like
a size four or something and they they
said she was a plus-sized model
and maybe like a month ago this Chef
went like viral on Tick Tock and she was
making tabloids because she quoted a
picture of like Tyra and [ __ ] in like
velor sweats looking
a little bigger and she was like
remember when you called me a plus size
model or something like that pretty
simple what and what spikes
um do Chef Rachel Tyra tweet
and then uh days later we had uh Chef
Rachel on our podcast another blow deck
podcast
she was burning all bridges she had ever
had
saying bro that's created her didn't pay
that's the outfit yeah
hmm
I'd still go for it oh absolutely that'd
be a good how tall is Tara she's like
she's like six foot or something so she
must she must be you know pretty big
then man I wore out a 1998 swimsuit
[ __ ]
what uh oh you're jacking off
I mean I mean if you want to get
scientists
yeah sticky pages
I mean masturbating hey why you put the
accent in there dude
you jerk you touch yourself hate crime
does anybody got a bathroom key on them
I have to pee
and then uh
and should we talk Chronicles of
Christian leaving a life if he shouldn't
lead you're going to 279 this weekend
you was you're freaking kidding dude
seriously are we still doing the uh like
fans
uh the tournament yes I'm just lazy
[Music]
oh we're going to oh [ __ ] yeah but so
Kevin Kevin Holland uh got Kevin Hollins
really good friends with my brother so
Gianni asked for tickets I think Kevin
reached out to him and asked if he
wanted to come and worked out for me
because it was supposed to be Gianni
Michael
um Michael's videographer and Michael's
security all going to the fight but
they're going back to New York for
Michael's birthday who's his birthday is
a day after mine so John is like you
know what this is your birthday present
UFC 279 we're gonna so like me Gianni
our roommate Brandon and uh Daniel
sanjada who's also on power we're all
going up to Vegas Saturday morning to
watch yeah so yeah and then I mean
thinking with uh the homie my friend
Sasha who fights
um he's cornering Dodd this weekend so
they should be very interesting
cornering oh d-rod yeah Daniel Rodriguez
why'd you say yeah dot oh no no wait
because he said I'm high he said dot
um that's so freaking cool though man so
you got your your double dipping here
you got you got your stakes in Kevin
Holland and Daniel Rodriguez Dodd Dodd
I opened it madly yeah it's d-rod
there's no other Dodd in there yeah uh
he's like that's BTS oh no draw that's
d-road come on Christian you're acting
like this is the [ __ ] Galaxy Garden
Guardians of the Galaxy
it is a nickname but it's d-rod not yeah
but the way I read it because he didn't
put he didn't put a dash no it just it
was d-r-o-d so okay
he messed up then he should put the dash
how do you not know the guy that your
buddy is fighting it's he's Kevin
Alexander my buddies Gianni's boy I've
never met him that's so cool man Sasha's
more my buddy than him oh how lucky this
guy is dude I want to link up with
Adrian I asked him if he was going to be
there
um he said he'd next uh he said he's not
gonna be able to make the next one but
yeah come on we had an interesting
Channel Christian so where are you
sitting do you know where your seat um
oh my God it's it's in [ __ ] I
guarantee it's in like celebrity well
we'll be on camera area here's the thing
because I'm not gonna mention who but my
brother's actually whom really
just like that teachers I'm really good
at it
I just I just want to Mentor you okay
just let me mold your mind is that right
though Nick's gonna buy me uh I think
it's a yeah because he said uh I'm not
gonna mention who
and then you answer the question and to
whom are you talking about yeah yeah
yeah so if you would say
I I'm I mentioned I mentioned here so if
you say him I think he's done it too I
think it's I I think he said it right he
did it hopefully someone hey
basis
he would say I'm not gonna mention who
who yeah yeah
when you said he's uh that I was right I
was just looked at you he goes did
anyone just hear him say drawer
um Christian's favorite comic is drawd
Carmichael
um so I'm not gonna mention who I wanted
to say and he was wrong
um but I'm not gonna mention who my my
brother's ex-girlfriend's dating but
she's dating a UFC fighter she's been
going to a lot of the fights and but the
fight that he fought we thought she
would be in Celebrity seating everything
and she was in the nosebleeds whoa yeah
so it did make us feel like a little
better made us feel a little better and
I'm guessing this UFC star or UFC
fighter is a pretty big name yes okay
okay yes that's kind of I'll give a hint
he's easily one of the ugliest people in
the UFC I just [ __ ] up but his name
rhymes with Sean or magger
yeah right by the way that sounded
really true it sounded very close to
another thing come on chin don't cancel
me bro I don't want to cancel you but
yeah I that doesn't surprise me that
some groupie [ __ ] got [ __ ] groupie
[ __ ]
I'll believe it bro I don't know why you
guys were like
that made me feel better then Nick said
that that made me feel like
um so so the main thing I'm just [ __ ]
guys from power and UFC guys I don't I'm
sorry I don't know
she didn't even watch UFC before she
started dating Johnny okay right I think
Nick's got a point there yeah she had no
idea what UFC what the reason why it's
such like a pain in the ass and like
that irks all of us is we showed her
what UFC was Janet would have UFC watch
parties every weekend and she's like I
want that one well now now somebody else
is showing her what UFC is all I know is
we're gonna have to hold Gianni back
because he can't get his ass kicked by
this person because we're all [ __ ] if
he does so putting zero effort into this
yeah do you got any shoes yeah he's too
smart like
it'd be a bad look to get your ass
kicked uh Gianni's on a PR wave right
now he's killing he's already [ __ ] up
that other white guy yeah [ __ ] Tommy
yeah that's official I don't know if the
dark stance is [ __ ] Tommy who's Tommy
Thomas
Joseph
so I like Gary Johnny Johnny had beef
with Joseph sikora uh who he plays Tommy
on the original Power Johnny basically
replaced him because he's just better
and Tom's ugly and just kind of cheese
and old yeah he's like being phased out
what I'll get is why he's so jealous he
has his own spin-off finish
so 50 invited Johnny and Mike to Tycoon
weekend and what is Tycoon weekend 50
cents weekend in Houston okay
um was that where they were doing the
dance with they were doing the dance
with a b and um 50 Cent I know that I
know maybe but so 50 brought them all on
stage and like was introducing everyone
and Gianni Michael went up dap Joseph
Sakura up Gianni went up to Joseph
segolic he topped his back and like
Joseph turned looked at Gianni looked at
his hand and then just said nah I'm like
turned away and everyone started calling
out like why are you acting all salty so
Gianni just kind of like rode the wave
and kind of made him look like a bigger
idiot and it made like
it's on like the shade like the biggest
Hollywood gossip sites they're 50s beef
50 posted a bunch of times Hollywood
gossip sites yeah but is it more urban
yeah uh but Urban
socialites are what runs like yeah the
paparazzi at the moment like the it you
know if you're talking about the younger
demographic yeah it was like the biggest
yeah that counts that like
I was seeing Gianni pop up on [ __ ] I
don't follow like because he's right
where where's the show at uh Houston
yeah Houston Texas baby
that's a huge ass [ __ ] arena is this
the one when he now this this was just
50 bringing him out yeah I think he did
he post it
this is him dancing with Antonio Brown
and 50 and rainy
you might have to mute that
vertical
by nobody I'm keeping our Lotus it's
amazing that uh that's a vibe
yeah and Antonio Brown literally just
acted like the most selfish head case on
the planet and is only furthered his
bottom line yeah
I don't
such a bad example but his tweet was
funny did you see his
oh yeah I can't remember what it was he
was like I don't uh look up Antonio
Brown Red Rocks tweet it was something
like
my biggest regret isn't quitting in the
middle of a game it's not it's not
running on my teammates uh it's the fact
that I haven't been able to see myself
play a game yeah it would be like uh
Jesus at Red Rocks
beautiful
right there
so is the beef still going on with the
with Johnny and uh the other dude the
other guy
can we bleep this because I don't know
how many people he wants to know but I
will obviously tell you guys Gianni's
gonna get him fired off the show no no
so Joseph I mean Joseph called and
apologized Tommy oh the guy who plays
Tommy because 50 posted this and was
like posting like Gianni like ripping
him apart
because 50 is like Fanning the Flames
this is all publicity for power oh yeah
for sure he says oh [ __ ] it's up I never
like to start [ __ ] but you should sock
him Tommy because Tommy like acted like
everything good I know that but I mean
that's the guy you're talking about I I
recognize that guy yeah okay yeah the
dollar store Eminem
I know the guy that is mistaken for you
or they look a lot alike yeah I was
gonna say he really looks like just like
a dollar store version of Slim Shady but
I mean it's in his his character or him
on the show he's like a badass right
yeah right yeah so now he's beefing with
you your brother my brother because
basically so in the first story it was
Ghost and Tommy it's true though yep in
the first story was Ghost and Tommy and
power and then the spin-off it goes
because he's white no ghost is ghost is
the name of the drug dealer it's like
the drug dealing like code for him like
his real name in the show was James St
Patrick which is Michael Rainey Jr's
father in the show uh because Michael
plays Tariq St Patrick so I feel like
I'm watching trapler Ross again yeah
this is our Iceberg this is the uh this
is a conspiracy our Iceberg the name of
the episode but uh he um so it's the
spin-off is basically Gianni and Michael
who are basically the new Tommy and
ghosts like it's it kept it on the Block
yeah literally and it kept the main
power our fan base because it's just a
continuation of the show meanwhile Tommy
Joseph scorer show is a spin-off like
and it's a different storyline it's not
like not like it can it is a
continuation but it's not going to have
the same reach I don't think does it say
is it called Power book three uh it's
PowerBook for Force oh there so there is
there is yeah it's it's smart how
they're doing it they're like oh is that
my under the same umbrella it's like
instead of making movies they're making
series they did Bibles for like shitty
black television yeah they did something
I mean black towel
genius the way they did it because they
did power book two ghosts which is a
continuation then they did power book I
think three is Raising Kane and which is
the prequel to power uh to power it's
it's like 50 Cent like growing up I'm
gonna put 50 cents over this again
his dad was talking about Skype security
we can change it we're on YouTube so
it's all a tangent off of 279. so you
went to the strip club with your brother
and you picked up money off the floor
I texted you so that's ridiculous yeah
Christian come on he immediately
threw it back down yeah he regurgitated
back he's not [ __ ] putting in his
pocket he's just keeping the energy
going yeah you picked it up and threw it
again yeah okay okay that's that's fine
I throw all my own money then once it
hits the floor I pick my own money up
again and I throw it again it's my money
I should be able to do whatever I want
with it okay
I'm throwing my money I can't even see
it I'm the one in the white you're doing
this right now you try to make it look
like more you just picked it up look at
how okay guys
oh yeah I mean I love that you did that
but you can't do that oh what the hell
it's definitely
it's definitely gonna be frowned upon I
just don't think that's money spent
already yeah
exactly spending more money hey man it
was my first time at the strip club I
was [ __ ] your first time that was my
first time ever holy [ __ ] it's way
different than when I went and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Valley Minnesota
place
that is a great [ __ ] name
I actually haven't been I went to one
strip club in Wisconsin Wisconsin Dells
the water park capital of the world and
it's called cruise and Chubbies
which one were you
I was the Guy cruising for Trump
what does that mean cruising Chubbies
you're true you're cruising Perfection
it means something different to everyone
I think it's an admittance that you're
not getting top shelf ladies at this
place The Bargain Bin it doesn't make
sense though Cruise unless it's c-r-u-z
and that's the owner I like it I like to
think about it as like a dynamic duo
like Cruz and chubby like just like that
too yeah
I've been lamenting there's just no
buddy cop movies anymore
yeah [ __ ] cruise and chubby have you
seen it dude you mentioned that buddy
copy you could play both parts if you
like lose weight
yeah film half of it now and then when
he gains weight again
that's brilliant that that is like that
Jonah Hill or someone like that done
that that is honestly like a concept
that I bet we will see that is so funny
I should have a really fat version of
your like Mac from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia could do it yeah just all
jacked and then really fat that'd be so
funny if I hated myself more I could try
it but I'm chilling right now
these are all right right now yeah yeah
I'm trying the best I can there's a
place there's a strip club in Kentucky
near my house almost took Chen to where
you put you pay five dollars for one
hand of lotion do you pay five dollars
for the other hand of lotion and you
just get to do like you just rub the
stripper
it's moisturizing that's all it is some
of these ones in the boonies in
Wisconsin they're BYOB
bring a cooler really yeah
we're just like I'm actually feeling
pretty
actually you got five dollars
[Laughter]
really they've just rubbed it on
themselves instead oh no I don't know
about that maybe someone that was just
nice
that sounds like a Theo joke I am a
little disappointed that that strip club
wasn't full of nudity so it was like a
little down a little disappointed in
that I'm not gonna lie but I feel like I
sure got the whole like excuse worded
the right room yeah no that was the
entire room
the only reason we were there was
because Mike uh knew the guy there so
he's like all right well it was a bull
dude bro there were the most gorgeous
girls there that weren't even strippers
yeah that weren't even strippers where'd
you guys go
I can't even remember the name oh a nice
place
I need I think we went to Nightingale
and then we went there after which now
you got what kind of talked about that's
a strip club as well no it's just yeah
that sucks yeah
they have strippers there but they like
the club
that kind of surprised me I've been yeah
yeah and all those places suck yeah
clubs are [ __ ] that was my first
night at a club too I I don't Club I
don't go out really so I went to uh
Delilah for Bieber's birthday uh not
Bieber's birthday Bieber's drummer's
birthday with Gianni which was
interesting but I was like I know it's a
big difference yeah huge difference
Bieber did come out and perform though
which was wild I was like I'm used to
like going to like like going out and
like them playing songs on the radio and
everything and
I'm not gonna lie that our table was
fire it was me my brother Mike and then
this guy named slip slim who is Machine
Gun Kelly's hype man and keyboardist and
dub who's like another artist and like
uh Michigan Kelly's best friend we're
all at a table and we were there for
like two hours at the time so like the
night was kind of like dying down we
were all like taking a break and I tear
peaches come on by Bieber and I'm just
like sitting on my phone like look like
looking down and everyone starts
standing up I'm like wait why is
everyone standing he's like everyone
wants to see Bieber perform I get up I
just see Bieber performing in the middle
of the club after his verse he drops the
mic and then just dipped it was the most
G [ __ ] you got 50 Grand yeah it was
insane did you like stand on it 50. I
did you probably caught a [ __ ] for a
minute for minutes
yeah but also add his friend's birthday
part at his drummer's birthday party I
feel like he wasn't gonna try and [ __ ]
the club over I feel like he would have
done it for everyone
you might be right yeah but that sticks
right okay bro yeah yeah yeah how long
have we been and it's been really fun
but I feel like it's been like hours and
a half yeah
should we was there more UFC too you
guys got to talk about we even talk
about it do we barely
we I mean we've
yeah let's look at the card and and
sorry we got sidetracked did you see no
that's I think this is all great like
this is really fun but
freaking watched thick boy fight news on
extra thick we gotta moved to a
different channel for shorter content
watch it algorithm baby freaking uh Diaz
said that he he was like I haven't been
training for this fight just beat me
that was literally his quote to MMA
junkie he said I haven't been training
for this fight beat me man I want
challenge accepted I I might [ __ ] put
like three thousand dollars sometimes at
hey I mean but what if you I feel like
Diaz would beat I honestly feel like
what if Diaz is just doing psychological
[ __ ] where he's like making it sound
like he doesn't really give a [ __ ] I
think 100 he's doing that yeah yeah
I don't believe that he is not training
no yeah I believe he is gonna get thrown
around the ring like [ __ ] see I think
I think if he can stop like keep uh keep
cosmet from engaging clinches keep
cosmet from taking him down I think Diaz
wins because Diaz I feel like Diaz has a
longer gas tank cosmod couldn't put
Gilbert down no one the only person
who's finished Diaz is Josh Thompson
like this is a beautiful narrative but
it started off if Nate diaz.com from
taking him down you say McDonald took
him down seven seven times
I know Hamza Hamza come shot or comes on
[ __ ] shot no no you're not Kobe you're
not good
I think Kevin that Kevin uh yeah sorry I
don't know
follow your heart Nick what do you want
to talk about uh just that Kevin Howell
derive fight it's gonna be amazing yeah
that's one of you that's probably gonna
be the fight of the night it has to be
right uh
we should we should try to get them both
in here I I I didn't think it's very I
don't know what drod for sure we can get
yeah
um but yeah in studios even more fun
that where does Kevin Allen live out
here I think uh Vegas now no he he's
probably here he's been stopping crimes
he got arrested trying to stop a crime
recently he was like I'm done trying to
stop crying they arrested me really yeah
I didn't hear that one what happened he
like he just like enter like he
interjected himself in a situation he's
all tatted everywhere maybe that's like
one of the reasons why they think he's
like a thug
so when you're saying um Christian when
you're saying he's gonna toss him around
dude you remember Roy McDonald versus
yeah Nate oh my god dude it was insane
he tried to
gift wrap him a million dollars and they
just couldn't do it and I I [ __ ] love
Rory McDowell that really bummed me out
but but also Ching going on that I I
think Cosman is not gonna win what am I
saying Hazmat
or comes up what did I says
put the M before the Z that's it it's
the case Island because they're like no
you can do the K or or silent k but
still just put the M before the Z come
shot I'm just gonna call Matt
um he um I feel like he's gonna have
some wanna prove something and prove
that he can stand and bang and I think
he's going to try and send banglades
because he says he's gonna kill him he's
not gonna kill him by just taking him
down and laying on him I he come fight
me I take his head off I eat his heart I
don't care brother this guy exactly so I
think he's gonna you're doing Brazilian
but don't do you agree I think George
has gotten too high I'm not one to
[ __ ] hurt someone's mellow
but do you guys think that could happen
like do you guys see that happening or
not
like I think it's been clear that I was
just contemplating putting three
thousand dollars
well actually I forgot it's my I was
thinking it was minus 800 so then you
could win 400 but that'd be the only be
you'd only win 200 dude but three
thousand dollars I'm not gonna do that
I know it dropped like within minutes of
us talking on shop show it dropped like
a few hundred or like oh can you go to
Best Buy it's been tightening right yeah
I think it's getting closer for sure
wait Diaz is a favorite no oh no dude
he's the he's probably one of the worst
odds in the in recent memory for UFC uh
can you go to 279
right there all the way on the right I
see this page and it is it's a I'm
reading you know like I I I go to I go
to best fight odds every single day that
was my favorite thing to use but once we
got sponsored by DraftKings I can't go
there anymore
interesting but so many more props yeah
yeah
um
me and Nick are the two highest people
on the show and we're trying to explain
this to Chris I'm explaining it pretty
well this will all be cut out so high I
don't know what's going on I want to
hear about uh George's uh recent open
mics uh before we close out who's Mike
yeah I did uh
white mics
um this week sucks tonight at the
Hollywood Improv
was it last Friday or two Fridays ago
um is that the one where you get
critiqued
kind of more just a rose but but you do
stand up and then yeah so basically the
show is there um Mike and then the
co-host Anwar they're in suits and they
do like 30 minutes of like a weekend
update kind of thing uh slideshow like
PowerPoint like funny stuff and then
they bring on four comics and they stay
on and then yeah you like do jokes and
then like they interject and like the
crowd like interjects and it's a lot of
fun it's like a really like entertaining
because like like I go to a lot of like
stand-up stuff and it just like it gets
really old like hearing the same so it's
a good like way to like bring a
different vibe into a show it was really
great
um but it was interesting for sure
because uh do they sell tickets to that
yeah
and then yeah and it was where at the
Hollywood improv yeah in the lab um but
yeah it was a lot of fun uh it was
interesting to be put in that place
um because like as a comic when you go
up on like a normal show like you're in
control of like what's going on but this
you're like the least like in control
out of anyone because they're up there
and then the crowd kind of gets in it
too like how much will they let you like
is it constant interruptions or will
they actually let you kind of get stuff
out and then they're like at breaks or
you just like constantly essentially
having a conversation it kind of depends
for me I kind of started a race war at
the beginning so um
divided coincidentally
um let me explain it was funny so they
during their like no explanation needed
that's a good move so um I probably I
was up there for like eight minutes and
I I maybe did like two minutes of actual
material like they brought up Pornhub
behind me
um but mine was kind of crazy not all
the comics were as intense
um but after me like the white girl who
went after me because I started the race
where you can just say girl um nobody
like why'd you have to say it because
people say because like her being after
me and I started the race war she got
some of the repercussions too
oh yeah I I I wanted to let it slide but
I need to know how you started it now I
need to know so during during their um
like Weekend Update thing it was the
first Friday after the house of the
Dragon Game of Thrones got on okay what
was that on and they were talking about
this character
um cordless Valerian who was a like this
badass black dude he's this badass black
character and it's like oh about time
like Game of Thrones like has a black
character it's been like 13 years but
for book readers you know that in the
book he's a white guy but they changed
it you know to making black in a show so
I went up there and I brought that up
and they're like oh you're taking like
our moment or whatever like you nerd you
read the books and stuff and like I was
like oh shoot like I wasn't expecting
that I just want to get to the punch
line and the punch line was like oh
these book readers like they're cool
with Dragons but black people is where
they draw the line so I I was actually
on their side but I didn't really get
the chance to like get to the punch in
time to like make it work out so then
the whole like show like my set from
there on out was like oh they would like
bring that back up and stuff and I was
like I'm going to Hollywood yeah
but it was fun it was a really good show
I White Mike I'm sure was uh igniting
that fire uh in regards yeah
but it was a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun and I was appreciative of the
opportunity good learning experience too
um I would do it again I don't know if
they'd let me do it again
why do you not think you did well no I
think I think it was fine um and it was
it was entertaining for the crowd for
sure
um yeah yeah it was good yeah yeah
that's awesome that does sound like a
fun show and I know to get what you mean
about especially I mean the open mics
it's just like there's no enthusiasm in
the crowd yeah so you can't really gauge
if you're being funny yeah but if it's a
different vibe by the time this is
posted it'll already be passed but
tonight
him and Chappelle yeah opening for
Chipotle
Irvine Improv that's wild yeah excited
tonight I'm not going well tonight right
tonight yeah 8 P.M yeah I heard you I
heard you start race Wars at your show
so I'm not going it's not in my normal
set guys just when I'm don't worry so I
gotta be white people there
[Laughter]
um
George Harris
um are you guys gonna do the fight today
or not
oh yeah yeah you got it yeah I'm gonna
pee let's do it let's do it all right go
for body shots Bros all right I'm gonna
go record the news all right do you ever
watch the fight how are you guys
starting right now yeah we're gonna spin
it no no oh oh we're gonna I'll put I'll
put the results we're spending for next
week's first
you want to spend before the flight for
next week yeah I think
then we don't have to so so you don't
like being a [ __ ]
no uh
we've talked about how we want to do it
we gotta accuse The Click we've got
accused of Click bait uh because of our
fight last time uh
which it was and it was effective uh but
uh we'll do it again we'll make it up to
him and uh right now all right and all
right I was like [ __ ] I had three beers
I'm actually kind dude
it was literally like the drunkest fight
I've seen
yes but we're gonna spin for next okay
spin it
I'm just gonna say if I get picked I
might call my retirement wow you guys
are [ __ ] no other people gotta fight
you I can't be the one me again
maybe it's just chin versus someone
chin versus the series because I
oh yes I feel sorry for Kyle just stay
wait we're because we I want to wrap the
show
don't bring them in for a little press
conference but next week
just right when we fight yeah he's got
to do the news yeah yeah
what are we doing we're fine oh we're
wrapping in you what's up we're gonna
box yeah all right
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
get it bro
welcome to the main event of the cats
after dark Studio
[Music]
ladies
[Applause]
yeah
in the ring but we are live here with
our main event who are you punching in
versus Nick two
question mark because uh the first one
was questionable Nick's looking loose
they are they say they're going hard
should be
but will they go hard like George Harris
we will find out oh he's doing the
McGregor next game Nick has a real
confidence
all right ready kick us off who's
getting the timer going I got the timer
all right I'm ready you gotta be the
rest three two One Dingo
oh
[ __ ] let's go what a dog fight oh okay
okay oh
oh nice oh my God
oh that's producer problems
oh
oh [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen this truly
is a fight of the ages oh that gets
another one
hey
Nick's looking a little wobbly Center
recenter boys
in a row
Nick's looking a little scared no he's
coming back I got faith in your neck
come on baby 10 seconds left will chin
going for the Finish
oh he backed it up by Nick three oh two
oh one that's it that's it that's it
respect
respect that was good that is not click
bait we drink alcohol before this wow
wow
you guys are going to add it dude that
was a lot harder than I thought you got
10 19.
that was great that was awesome I I
agree with that honestly that's in our
fight news today yeah
we'll put in the Friday Funnies Friday
Funnies for sure that fight was actually
a lot better than I thought it was going
to be yeah respect boys that was a good
fight I think it was lackluster
commentary from you guys but great fun
time you're just sitting there watching
I was trying to I was just going to oh
oh all right Joe bro hey they each got
chain-hearted couple solid I felt like
when I hit him I felt like chin was
letting me get it back yeah no I felt
like he sat there and like let me
because it was just like so open the
couple times they did hit you I knew
once I knew once I didn't hit you hard
first I knowing chin he definitely felt
bad and that's why I think he would I
hit him in the face first though yeah uh
but I think all around great fight from
both of you I know China is that sneaky
right hand I also cannot see
Nazi I can't see
oh yeah
that was fun great fight all right
I don't know who won honestly I think I
know yeah
no let's let the next time two Coors
Lights I'm like counting strikes in my
head I'm like I gotta get one back okay
I will get one back Nick's calculating
to over under the lifestyle right now
the Pete Rose of the mma's I'm impressed
by Nick by the way I didn't know he had
that in him
honestly this is just a sponsorship from
altar training everyone signed up to
join Georgia tonight I gotta say I'm
excited I will say after watching that
Kyle is screwed
he doesn't know yeah well
we got a quarter Kyle bro hey so I
substituted for brows so Kyle something
substitute no yeah any volunteers it's
true
suggested before that come on shrimp you
got it baby I kind of want to see we do
you versus chin then universe made for
like double click me I would die yeah
you said when someone said 30 seconds I
was like you have got this
yeah like three times
those highlights are going to be sick
though yeah because you you punch chin
into the wall at one point
wobbled I did yeah that was [ __ ] you
put chin in the window at one point dude
[Music]
knockout that was really fun like
honestly I'm not so I just
I just wish I would have lived far and
found fighting sooner that was the most
fun I've ever had I honestly felt like
this weekend's Main Event honestly I
could be more exciting who knows all
right
plugs
uh 12 packs with Jeff dye moved to a new
YouTube channel subscribe to 12 packs
with Jeff dye on YouTube check out thick
boy fight news on extra thick
my Instagram George harris48 somebody
else help me take it away
um yes exactly the same thing George
said 12 packs of Jeff die and uh big boy
fight news yeah so welcome to cats after
dark we got a big show today we're
talking about UFC 279 chennager fight at
the end can't wait for the show is this
the cold open no the bit is that I I can
I thought if I kept going you guys would
get it I got it all right I'm gonna miss
your guys's plugs to go do the news I'm
sorry it's all good I'll watch them know
for sure I don't believe that neither do
I uh Instagram cpl06 Tick Tock
christian.phalo uh you already know
podcast on Instagram Tick Tock and uh
YouTube yeah
little browse got a song coming out
called First Flight featuring Austin
awake it comes out in one week on
September 10th nope I'm sorry September
15th check it out
Nick that was amazing I'm also not
realizing like how [ __ ] crazy that is
that like that's 1 15th of a fight I
know and the amount of impact on your
head it that is that is yeah insane
check out another podcast
thanks guys guys
[Music]
[Music]